welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about why the key
to success for any secret headquarters
for a team of superheroes is location
location location location location
location
my name is mt and i'm here today with my
big head gang brother tommy bechtol
what's going on what is up my man big
head gang forever peaches and cream
forever shower gang never back although
i do have to stay i recently stayed in a
hotel with a large bathtub i don't know
if it was for gentlemen of specific
sizes or if i just got lucky maybe it
was one of those hook-up hotel rooms
where they're like you paid by the hour
and i took a bath i tried it i tried to
get into bath culture it was not for me
it was not for me you know i'm not a
bathroom i don't like to bathe you're
not a bad guy
that's two good things about it
not a bathroom not a birther that's what
i say that's what they're gonna say at
my funeral not a bathroom not a birther
all right hit me with that big question
tommy
all right mt
what's the most valuable item in the mcu
is it dr strange's watch collection one
of tony stark's audis scott lang
shagging wagon hello
real estate baby
it's real estate
land is king if you want to have equity
in the mcu you got to have a piece of
land sure that land could be blown up by
aliens launched into the sky by a
tyrannical ai
or be the birthplace for a 300-mile tall
celestial but that's just the trials and
tribulations of owning property and
don't even talk to me about reverse
mortgages tom selleck but
there is one important building in the
mcu whose current ownership
is still a big mystery and that leads us
to this week's big question
dot dot dot my question for you mt my
big head gang brother who currently owns
the avengers tower in the mcu
um
that is a great question tommy thank you
ever since we saw spider-man uses armpit
web wings to glide through the new
atrium cut into the former avengers
tower in spider-man far from home we
have wondered who the new owner of this
building could be and since we have yet
to receive an answer despite several
series and shows being released since
that moment we are left scratching our
heads about just who the new landlord
could be remember avengers tower was
originally stark tower making its first
owner the late tony stark rest in peace
rest in peace 3000 my friend but after
making several structural and energy
modifications to the building and
learning to be a team player tony
decided to share his toys and turn the
building into a base for him and the
homies and then let's be honest
right here because i've always had the
theory the only reason that tony
benevolently decided to donate that
building to the avengers tower was some
sort of tax deal like someone found out
tony had been hiding
funds in some sort of illicit way and
they were like here's how you can make
it right you turn that into a vendor
because there's no way tony stark would
have unselfishly just donated that
awesome building to the avengers genius
billionaire playboy philanthropist
it had to have been some sort of
financial windfall for him to do it oh
absolutely like dude like he he probably
went through so many hoops just to get
his name on the building that's right
and then his name just got toward the
pieces he's like oh man you know what
like you know he he there has to be a
reason why but then of course he created
ultron big mistake who wrecked the place
and almost destroyed the planet whoops
should have just went to therapy
then he decided to sell this monolith of
mistakes and move his crew upstate and
the ownership of this tower has actually
been a small subplot in the spider-man
films with the sailor tower happening in
spider-man homecoming and there happy
hogan was juggling overseeing the move
and monitoring the actions of the
friendly neighborhood spider-boy on the
side leaving him all those voicemails
why am i hearing about churros i don't
care about churros
jesus christ yeah
i would be just as annoyed as happy and
in a recent interview with comicbook.com
tom holland was asked about who the new
owner of avengers tower was and he
cheekily in his british accent indicated
that he does know who the new owner is
and then his main squeeze zendaya had to
shut him up before he spilled the beans
and got executed by the foggy hit squad
because they do exist i've seen the
laser pointers oh it's a hidden mickey
but this could have been a fun little
gag calling back to all the times
holland has accidentally leaked secret
mcu info or maybe he does know who
actually bought the tower i mean like we
said spider-man and avengers tower was
strangely linked but until he actually
shares the secret we're left guessing so
let's look at the likely candidates for
the owners of the building and see if we
can't just figure it out on our own
let's begin with someone who is a
looming figure in the nyc real estate
and recently made his official return to
the mcu wilson fisk aka kingpin aka the
fresh prince of this city i would love
uh wilson fisk fresh prince crossover
i got in one little flight vanessa
vanessa my mom got scared
i'm just picturing like you know how it
starts off with will like spitting out
the chair
the chair just breaks
like it barely turns it's just like
this wilson's fists this guy loves to
buy property especially fancy buildings
that he can stand on the top floor and
just leer over amenities at the city
below just thinking about vanessa
vanessa you know technically he is part
of the big head gang so even though i
don't always approve he is what he does
i i can't exclude him from the big head
gang because he's kind of a founding
member and he makes a good omelet he
makes a delicious spinach and egg omelet
and his real estate dealings were also
part of the plot of the netflix
daredevil show so it makes sense that
they would bleed over into the mcu and
mr fisk just made his grand return in
the hawkeye series where clint barton
reminds kate bishop that tony sold
avengers tower years ago so why mention
it in the same show that has wilson fisk
if he's not actually the new owner kind
of weird kind of weird but one element
that potentially hurts this theory is
that on hawkeye kingpin did seem a
little down and out working out of an
auto mechanic shop burying hawaiian
shirts but this doesn't seem like this
lavish style that we've known kingpin to
know or it's possible that he's learned
a lesson and he's conducting his
criminal businesses in a less
conspicuous location so what do we think
about kingpin being the owner of
avengers tower tommy
you know i i like the theory it
definitely works for me but i think that
there's a sexier answer out there you
know i think like kingpin
is a you know he's a he's a rich
new york guy it would make sense for him
to own it but i just there's something
more exciting afoot i think for the
avengers tower i don't want to reveal
what my theory is but i'll let you know
if you're getting warmer let's just say
this kingpin seems like fun okay i think
there's something a little closer we do
know
that the fantastic four will be in the
mcu okay now that's actually directly
what my theory is
so you don't have to wait period on the
same wavelength
that's the big head gate connection we
just connected like like like the old
game boys when you wanted to trade a
pokemon that's how we trade information
right we just it's like
alright here we go so we know that the
fantastic four will be in the mcu very
soon this could mean that reed richards
aka mr fantastic is the new owner of
avengers tower maybe because in the
comics the baxter building in new york
is a skyscraper that serves as a
headquarters for marvel's first family
like they hang out there they work there
conduct experiments there and just
generally around and find out there with
the negative zone and their own little
slice of new york city but with their
appearance in the mcu still somewhat in
the distance is it possible tommy that
they're already just hanging out there
just uh you know just putting up their
their family photos here's the time we
went to yosemite and reed stretched as
tall as old faithful here's our trip to
the golden gate bridge where reed
stretched as tall as the golden gate
bridge and here's our trip to chicago
where reed stretched as tall as the old
sears tower actually come to think of it
we only go places where reed can stretch
real tall
what a selfish selfish father he is
he has a complex yeah he's got a problem
that is the one that i think i think the
way that the mcu has kind of brilliantly
like woven in
uh these characters as they get entered
into the marvel cinematic universe
rather than shoehorning in all of their
details they just kind of
they they weave them into the existing
world i think rather than establishing a
new baxter building making the avengers
tower the baxter building makes more
sense to me in this universe i mean as
we learned from
uh no way home there's now a million
different possibility like you know
every universe can have things done the
right way to like if comic book fans are
going to be outraged there can certainly
be a fantastic four that exists in toby
maguire's
you know universe or another
spider-man's universe that has a baxter
building that is separate from avengers
tower but i think with the state of the
avengers in the way that they've moved
on in these movies it makes sense to
kind of have the new team
stay in the existing building that we
know has all that awesome stuff so
that's my thought no i i definitely
agree with you for sure because like you
know like we said
the avengers tower was originally stark
tower and like that was he was a man of
science and like that was an originally
a science building and where he was
probably gonna do a lot of his nerd
stuff it just makes perfect sense for
the science man reed richards and his
family to just move in and just be like
all right i was gonna do science
shenanigans in the actual main place
where like the mcu got its like official
sort of start with avengers 1. let's do
science shenanigans that's exactly what
they that's their that's their
catchphrase let's do science yeah
that's the fantastic four
science shenanigans
i always say that a good fantastic four
movie should feel like rick and morty
married to the um the incredibles like
those those two things should have a
baby that's fantastic four like it
should be science [ __ ] and it gets to
the max that tower should be like rick's
garage of like what's happening here
there's [ __ ] like there's dimensional
monsters popping out
helpers
[Laughter]
we also cannot forget he who remains
himself k i am so glad you said kang
kang is my pick to have the avengers
tower i have always thought there's no
way anyone other than kang is going to
be in charge of this tower from day one
he's being set up as a major villain in
the mcu it's got to be chaos yeah you
know what i got that vibe from the first
two and i was like you know what i think
he's more of a jonathan major star than
anything else just hang around you might
learn something all right
we're just ganging around
um
big head kang
peaches and cannons
i guarantee you kang has never taken a
bath in his life kang showers under
mystical waterfalls and that's it
[Laughter]
we know that kang is being set up as a
major villain in the mcu could he
already be readying for battle by
setting up a base in nyc because if you
recall in loki we saw a vision of
avengers tower in the void that had a
kang written on the side of it where
avengers would normally be now this is a
reference to the comics where a variant
of kang starts a company called kang
enterprises in the comics tony actually
sells the tower to mr griffin of kang
industries who is actually nathaniel
richards a variant of king the conqueror
so was this loki easter egg actually a
subtle nod to what's currently going on
in new york city you know i i like that
idea i think it's i think it's
definitely plausible i just wonder
if the if kang
is going to have that type of like total
impact like is he going to be set up in
new york city like operating where
people are aware of him or is it going
to be like a
secretive or almost like god-like enemy
where he just shows up and has like an
epic battle you know what i mean like is
there going to be like a
almost like a like a kang for mayor
thing where people are like no we love
kang we think he's great and like the
the the masses have no idea what his
true malevolent purpose is or or is it
gonna be you know something slightly
more i think you know traditional to the
comics so that i i i think that although
kang is my pick and i have said all
along i think it will be kang i don't
think it's going to be kang so
prior to the release of spider-man away
home i think a few of us thought that
the film would reveal that oscorp now
owns the tower i mean yes and this has
always been my theory it's always been
oscorp it's gotta be norman osborne it's
gotta be aussie baby oh man ozzy with
the waves specifically i wish we had uh
willem dafoe with the waves let's get
that going
ozzy with the waves
i mean this tower does seem to always
show up in the spiderman films but the
norman osborne from the rain universe
said that there is no oscorp in the mcu
what the heck's going on there but there
is a possibility that norman was lying
to peter when he said that in an effort
to garner sympathy for him but that did
seem like a genuine norman moment there
and not the mischievous scheming of his
green goblin persona lurking behind
behind the cowardly eyes of norman
norman's answer sabbatical honey
honey
oh my god it's so creepy i hope i never
do that again my fingers are too long
it'd be something like this
let's isolate that clip and turn it into
an nft oh no don't do it no no
is it possible that oscorp now owns the
building and peter has a good reason to
be wary of their actions and what could
the mcu's norman osborne be up to as
peter swings alone in new york city oh
up to no good i bet no good or maybe
he's up to
no good for all my harry potter stands
out there
k-n-o-w
maybe we have iron patriot norman
osborne joining up with valentina and
maybe with their
mutual interest norman is the face
and val is the rest of the space if you
know what i'm saying i'm talking skull
neck spine everything else in the human
anatomy maybe she's working behind the
surface well norman is the face of the
company you know what i'm saying norm is
the puppet
valentina is the puppet master i i
really do love that idea but i am
patriot man i would love to see a norman
osborne iron patriot so badly i feel
like the the mcu norman osborne does
exist but like he's just up and coming
well that would be really cool if he was
actually younger than peter parker
they're like peter meet your meet your
uh intern or whatever hi i'm norman
[Laughter]
norman's taking a sabbatical from this
internship honey
all right now we've covered them all
now anyone who is watching this has
turned this off great mission
accomplished what about another big
company in the mcu buying out the
building because there's rocks on which
appeared in the first iron man film as
well as the loki series and also i think
was had a brief mention in iron man 3
with that executive that was being held
by
um the fake mandarin but also aim which
even though it had some leadership
issues in the past could be back on its
feet and growing again or even hammer
industries which may be trying to move
on from the disgrace that was justin
hammer but he could also dance really
well so i guess not that much of a
disgrace but but very graceful on the
feet i should say i don't think so no
this one i don't think this one i don't
think is possible i don't think there's
any chance of this
i'm kidding this is the one i've always
said is gonna happen it's gonna be an
old enemy an old financial enemy of tony
stark coming back to take out his legacy
this is the only way it could go i've
always said that it's got to be roxanne
aim or hammer industries and why not
justin hammer he's got to be up for
parole soon right it's time for a
rockwell assange though it doesn't seem
like the mcu is currently setting up
these companies to be a big presence in
the immediate future could any of these
people possibly be the owners of the
iconic tower yeah i i don't know these
ones i feel like are kind of almost a
little too they would work for an
individual movie i don't know about the
whole franchise of the mcu you know what
i mean like if they were making an iron
man 4 this would be a good plot point
but i think in terms of making uh movies
that have details that span over
multiple
franchises within the movie i think it's
i think it's a little too narrow i think
it's a little too narrow of an answer
hmm
you know what i i don't know i think
that roxon
is not really all that likely
considering that they're in the energy
business and like they wouldn't really
be using the building for anything
interesting um in the mcu wise i think
that aim
could be potentially because they're all
about technology and they're you know
they're all about you know just pushing
the envelope on on just being on the the
cutting edge of everything and beyond
that and like i think that especially
with the the coming of the the high
evolutionary and like you know the
and all the stuff with armor wars coming
up aim is slowly going to start building
up again um
this is just me just speculating um and
i think that aim would be a great little
um owner for the building and then i
would love to see modoc and like maybe
even a jim carrey murdoch likes being
rumored um just like be owning the
building and be like this is why i do
science stuff
i would love that but you know it's
definitely not as likely as the other
ones i feel you know something
you're right
now that shield is no more in the mcu
sword has appeared to slip right into
the void that they left behind say no
more i've always said it was gonna be
sword you're i mean that was number one
from the get-go i knew it would be sword
i have nothing else to say on this
matter you know what i you know i i when
you were talking about roxanne i was
like sword is the true
true thing that he really means i can
tell we're connected uh we are one um
that is why we were married just last
weekend we saw how much they had already
amassed resources in one division and we
know that nick fury has been hanging out
in their space station so could they
also have a purchased avengers tower in
order to have a base of operations in
new york city and with the looming
secret invasion coming to the mcu nick
fury might just want to have a building
he's familiar with to work out of what
do you think i think that makes perfect
sense in fact i think that does actually
make the most sense all kidding aside i
think having sword takeover operations
of avengers tower
in order to kind of like you said have a
familiar home base for a secret invasion
and giving nick fury i mean
who knows how much more nick fury we're
going to get over the next few years i
hope we get a lot more but samuel
jackson at a certain point is probably
going to want to you know retire or or
taper down his involvement one last
stand as the boss man in an avengers
tower i think is the perfect way to send
off our one-eyed king you know him like
at the top floor with this big old chair
with with with goose like a claw yeah i
think specter gadget like
getting you gotcha biopsy
yes but no i think that you know having
sword take over the tower would be a
really good next step because like it's
sort of just like
it it sort of it symbolizes the next
sort of ha phase or the new saga of the
mcu rather it's like all right we have
the avengers in this tower now and like
we had the whole shield thing going on
but now we're moving on to space and in
the multiverse and now sword is in the
tower and so like we're sort of it sort
of symbolizes this saga shift so i can
definitely see that being a little fun
um edition or a new thing that they do
there those are our biggest suspects in
the case of avengers tower tenants but
we gotta you know just wrap it up here
and i gotta ask you who is your best
guest for the current owner for the
tower like for real for real for real
for real i think it's sword i think it's
gonna be
nick fury and sword i might even just be
nick fury outright and this would be an
amazing way to like show he's just a
master
tremendous personal wealth behind the
scenes as an agent of shield for all
those years like he's just been like
like using trade secrets he was in on
cryptocurrency well before everyone else
was i i think my guess is it'll be a
sword building by the end when all is
said and done
what about you
okay okay i'm gonna say fantastic four
yeah i think that it makes a lot of
sense because like the baxter building
is a huge staple of fantastic four and
like that building has to go somewhere
and i can't think of a better place than
avengers tower like i can't those are my
two favorites those would be my two
favorites either a sword a sword base or
uh
or fantastic four would be would be my
top two if it were if they were making
them just for me just for tommy i hope
they're making them just for tommy just
for tommy that's my hair dye it only
works on my shade
just for tall men
red beard brown top
but hey check out our merch friends over
at new rockstarsmerch.com for some of
the coolest gear in the multiverse they
have great shirts inspired by spiderman
no way home book of boba fett peacemaker
and more and it's a great way to support
our channel while also looking really
cool and before we dive into our bite
size questions next some words from the
people that help bring us big question
to you people like masterclass because
with masterclass you can learn from the
world's best minds anytime anywhere and
at your own pace learn about science and
problem solving from bill nye improve
your cooking skills with roy choi or
learn songwriting from alicia keys with
over 100 classes from a range of
world-class instructors the thing that
you've always wanted to do is closer
than you think and that new rockstars
were drawn to the film and tv focus
classes they have some really awesome
classes from natalie portman spike lee
han zimmer and even a really cool
leadership class from former disney ceo
bob iger he's tell some really great
stories about pixar and marvel and give
some really helpful career advice and
the part i like best about masterclass
is that they're shot and structured in a
way that doesn't feel like a boring
lecture it feels like you're having a
conversation with a famous person that
just knows a lot about the topic that
you're interested in and they're super
addictive and i highly rec and i highly
recommend that you check master class
out so get unlimited access to every
master class and for the big question
audience get 15 off an annual membership
just go to masterclass.com
bigquestion right now that's
masterclass.com bigquestion for 15
percent off masterclass in honor of the
big game draftkings sportsbook
unofficial sports betting partner of
super bowl 56 is giving new customers
56 to one odds on either team bet just
five dollars and get 280
in free bets if your team wins
they don't give you better odds on on on
a coin toss which should be 50 50. we
leaned on new rockstars resident sports
and gambling expert myself and i confirm
that those are insane odds and trust me
i've lost a lot of money over the years
so i know all about odds speaking of
tommy draftkings sportsbook is now live
from new york meaning you can bet from
almost a third of the country now but
not in california because god for bid if
sportsbook isn't your in your state yet
play draftkings daily fantasy football
contest for super bowl 56 i can't
believe we're up to 56 of these damn
things so many opportunities to win and
lose download the draftkings sportsbook
app use the promo code big question and
get 56 to one odds on either team bet
just five dollars and get 280 in free
bets if your team wins that's promo code
big question at draftkings sportsbook
an official sports betting partner of
super bowl 56 you better bet the rams
you fools 21 plus minimum age and local
location requirements vary by
jurisdiction see draftkings.com
sportsbook for a full list of
requirements state-specific responsible
gaming resources boyd where prohibited
56-1
that is just insane gambling problem you
better believe i do call 1-800 gambler
in tennessee or call or text tennessee
redline
1-800-889-9789 in connecticut call
888-789-777
or visit
ccpg.org chat in new york
call 1-800 horny no that can't be right
in new york call eight seven seven eight
hope new ny
in new york
flew too close to the sun with that one
in new york call eight seven seven eight
hope ny or text hope ny four six seven
three
or text me and i'll tell you matt
stafford total touchdowns over two is a
lock baby i'm going all the way with it
and i may need to browse some money from
my daddy if it doesn't hit all right
what do you got for the bite size
questions
get ready because here we go
uh question one how heavy is a
lightsaber this is from iaj smith24 this
person is always sending the best
questions i aj smith thank you very much
uh i'm pretty sure that lights if i'm
not mistaken lightsabers are usually
measured in the units of d's these
they're about as heavy as these nuts
all kidding aside in the book of boba
fett we've seen
how the dark saber presents itself as a
heavy and unwieldy blade well in the
prequel trilogy jedis are jumping around
and twirling lightsabers like they're
lighter than air like little batons at
the rose bowl parade so which is it are
these things heavy or light it seems
like most of the weight of a lightsaber
is in its hill and the
plasma blade itself doesn't add much
additional weight however the blade is
created by channeling energy through the
kyber crystals in the weapon so well
it's not adding physical weight the
wielder of the lightsaber now has to
deal with the power of that flowing
energy this probably feels like added
weight that explains why jedi infamously
used this weapon since they are able to
utilize the force to help control and
use the blade cheaters when creating the
original trilogy george lucas conceived
the lightsabers as feeling like heavy
medieval swords of course he did in a
behind-the-scenes video
mark hamill talked about how george
described the lightsabers and he said
they go george we're marrying me that's
uh george lucas
george was adamant that these things
were really really heavy
that we couldn't take a hand off the
hilt we always had to have two on it was
like excalibur or my dick
40 to 50 pounds of weight that's a heavy
laser sword as for why they seemed so
much lighter in the prequels than they
did in the original trilogy it could
have come down to training with so many
jedi training with lightsabers from such
a young age and then constructing their
own blades it would make sense that they
would be much more adept at using them
effortlessly as time went on the jedi
were wiped out people were not as adept
at using their lightsabers thus the
heavy nature in the original trilogy and
as for the dark saber it might feel
heavier than all the other lightsabers
because it's one of the oldest sabers
out there and its ancient nature makes
it feel like a much heavier blade plus
it could also have a curse on it which
adds mystical weight just like me i
would be much lighter if that witch
didn't curse me as a boy i was too good
at little league so while the hilt of
the lightsaber might only weigh two to
five pounds the amount of energy you are
wielding and controlling makes the
lightsaber feel much heavier all right
you nerds is that good enough all right
now it is time for my favorite part of
the show but it's time for the box of
scraps of scraps
dummy if you could have a secret base
anywhere in the world where would it be
you know when i was a boy i dreamed of
being so old are so old i dreamed of
being so old no i dreamed of being so
rich
that my house would just be a
functioning
nba basketball arena so that i would
just like
i would have a hardwood court and then i
would sleep on the court and then take
my bet roll my bed away never thinking
about you know having like a woman there
with me it was always just like bachelor
style
wake up chug a gatorade shoot some hoops
then that witch cursed me and basketball
was out of the picture and sports like
wrestling and football
were more drawn to me no uh so i would
say i would like if i could have a
secret like secret base anywhere
in the world it would be like
it underneath a professional stadium and
i could just sneak up like the phantom
of the opera and watch games like
they're like who's that man and i'd be
like i'm watching the detroit pistons
play basketball
today
and then i go back down to my lair
what about you
i would probably
have some type of secret base somewhere
probably
antarctica somewhere like either north
like in the north pole or like an
antarctica or something just because
like you know if if for some reason the
apocalypse would go i'm not a doomsday
prepper first of all but if the
apocalypse were to go down i would love
a secret base or like zombies or like
any type of apocalypse scenario no one's
going to the north pole i will be fine
at the north pole i think that's perfect
plus if you go to the north pole there's
a 50 50 chance you team up with santa
exactly like i'm gonna have my bat cave
in the north pole and we have a team up
with santa batman santa team up exactly
if you go to the south pole there's a
50-50 chance you team up with satan
reverse santa oh
that's what santa does throughout the
year he's fighting satan
reverse santa yes
sage is just red with a white coat
and instead of ho ho ho he says
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's oh funny i think we just made a
new canon for christmas mm-hmm new
christmas okay i'm sure we didn't get it
but that is it for this episode of big
question i want to thank tommy for
taking the time out of his day to talk
to me thank you so much tommy my
pleasure anytime empty always a joy hey
please follow him tommy bechtel on
twitter he's an amazing person please go
follow him there follow me on
entertainment if you want to see me
tweet some really weird [ __ ] and crazy
theories more importantly follow new
rockstars wherever we are on the
internet twitter on youtube if you do on
youtube make sure to hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video please be sure to visit
newrockstarsmerch.com so you can get
really cool shirts like our peacemaker
stuff our spiderman stuff all of our
amazing stuff and go join us on discord
so you can continue the new rockstars
conversation there just make sure that
you are 18 years or older and you can
join us for game nights it's going to be
really fun we have some really great
times there so the link is in the
description for there but thank you guys
again for joining us we love you so much
and we appreciate you guys so much for
spending time with us yeah we'll see you
guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you